pensemos en lo que significa tener ocho
tercios y dividirlo entre un tercio
dibujemos una recta numérica
esta recta va del 0 y tenemos aquí un
entero y aquí otro entero y aquí el
extremo tenemos un tercer entero ahora
dibujaré los ocho tercios y para ello
debo dividir cada entero en tercios más
o menos así
y ahora contamos ocho tercios 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 aquí tenemos nuestros 8 tercios
ahora tomando esta longitud de aquí del
0 hasta estos 8 tercios nos preguntamos
cuántos saltos tengo que dar para llegar
a 8 tercios pero dando saltos de un
tercio o también podemos pensar en
dividir estos ocho tercios en secciones
de un tercio bueno cuántas secciones nos
quedarían vamos a ver vamos a dibujar
nuestros brincos
si queremos dar saltos de un tercio
vamos a tener aquí 1 2 3 4 5
7 y 8 en este brinco me quedo medio
extraño vamos a dibujarlo mejor ahora sí
8 nos llevó 8 saltos así que ocho
tercios entre un tercio es igual a ocho
porque esto tiene sentido al dividir
esto entre tercios por cada entero vamos
a tener tres saltos así que cualquiera
que sea el valor que tenemos en el
numerador tendremos que realizar ese
mismo número de saltos de un tercio para
llegar a él otra forma de verlo es que
si tenemos nuestros ocho tercios
divididos entre un tercio esto es lo
mismo que te mes ocho tercios tercios
que multiplican al recíproco de un
tercio es decir a tres entre uno y
nosotros ya sabemos cómo explicar
fracciones de hecho es bastante directo
es numerador o numerador y denominador
con denominador así que esto es igual
a tener 8 por 3 entre 3 por 1 que nos da
8 por 3 24 24 entre 3 es igual a 8 esto
es igual a 8 vemos si esto sigue
teniendo sentido ahora vamos a dividir 8
esos 8 tercios pero ahora lo vamos a
dividir entre dos tercios eso es lo
mismo que nos preguntaron al principio
si tenemos esta sección de 0 a 8 tercios
cuántos saltos de dos tercios necesitaré
para recorrer toda esta distancia bueno
vamos a ver lo voy a dibujarlo en otro
color un poquito más contrastante aquí
mi primer salto es de dos tercios otro
segundo salto de dos tercios un tercer
salto de dos tercios y finalmente un
cuarto salto de dos tercios por lo que
ocho tercios entre dos tercios es igual
a cuatro esto tiene sentido con esta
sección de multiplicar por el recíproco
bueno hagamos lo mismo ocho tercios
multiplicado por el recíproco si tenemos
dos tercios
va a hacer tres medios y tenemos que
esto es igual a 8 por 3 24 entre 3 por
26 y 24 entre 6 es igual a 4 tenemos la
mitad del resultado anterior lo que
tiene sentido pues en el primero tenemos
3 entre 1 y en este segundo ejemplo
tenemos 3 entre 2 y si vemos los saltos
en la recta numérica los saltos azules
abarcan el doble que los saltos de color
naranja por eso requerimos la mitad de
los altos cuando dividimos entre la
primera fracción por cada entero
hicimos tres saltos por lo que lo que
tenemos en el denominador de la fracción
que divide lo pasamos multiplican y lo
que tenemos en el numerador de esta
fracción que divide lo vamos a pasar
dividiendo y cuando el numerador de la
fracción que divide es mayor que 1 como
en este segundo ejemplo se avanza el
doble por lo que hay que dividirlo entre
2 espero que esto les ayude a comprender
el porqué al dividir entre una fracción
sé
por el recíproco